[Music]
hey folks welcome back to the dark horse
podcast live stream 123 q and a segment
indeed
we're gonna we're gonna make it a little
brief this week uh because we have some
things we need to be doing uh yeah that
are not right here late for a very
important date um yeah something like
that and we are we are bringing to you
today the left haunch of our favorite
epic tabby
okay uh from the discord this week they
had a tie
and i was thinking actually we might we
might take a stab at both of their
questions because they're both really
good they had a tie though it wasn't
required
they vote in the discord server every
week on which question they most want us
to answer and they're both very good
so
doesn't it make sense to leave god or a
conscious creator on the table as a fair
hypothesis rather than assuming that it
is factually incorrect but
metaphorically true
is it possible that our ability to
falsify or not has simply not matured
enough and we should keep trying the
meta-analysis sure seems compelling and
even einstein had to go at it and
couldn't falsify
great question
um no it does not um and the reason is
because
the underlying principle that allows us
to make sense of the universe and
everybody
all the philosophers are gonna
jump out of their chairs and shout at
the screen but um
is occam's razor the uh principle of
parsimony which is to say
you do not want more complexity in your
explanations than is necessary that is
to say the explanation that
i'm going to say this carefully so that
i believe it is ironclad
given
all
of the evidence
the explanation that explains most while
assuming least
is correct
absent all of the evidence it tends to
be correct so that is where we are we
lack a bunch of evidence we can't
observe everything but
here's the problem
with um
leaving
the idea of a creator and the idea of a
creator is formally left on the table we
could be living in a simulation in which
case we would have creators who had
designed the universe we would be in it
but i mean i guess that framing of
occam's razor
suggests given that we know that we
don't have all the information
um
that while our occam's razor strongly
strongly strongly
leads to the conclusion that there is no
additional complexifying uh thing in the
universe that we might call a god or
another creator
i actually am not sure how
the way that you invoke documents razor
doesn't lead us to
to leaving open the possibilities of
fair hypothesis oh it is open as a
possibility but it does not require
falsification for the following reason
but the question is doesn't it make
sense to leave it on the table as a fair
hypothesis and you said no
um because i take that to mean a
hypothesis in need of falsification
which it is not
it could be true we could have you know
if there if we are living in a
simulation which we would not be in a
position to detect
we would have a creator
and it would look to us like a universe
without a creator and yet there would be
you know there's a dude with a clipboard
taking notes on what we do here in the
simulation and he's got his own purposes
i suppose
so
it is open it could be but we assume it
to be false because
it doesn't
buy you any new explanatory power and it
increases the assumptions dramatically
so that is to say
if there is let's let's
say okay they've got it right we have a
creator
the creator built the simulation which
is the universe as far as we experience
it so it's just not even a stretch right
actually somebody had a purpose and they
made this thing and we live in it and
that's our universe
okay
where'd that come from
oh well they live in a simulation too
somebody made their universe right at
some point you're going to run into some
you're going to run into a universe that
wasn't made by somebody and then the
point is oh well what process created
that critter oh it's going to be an
evolutionary process and so the point is
you've got evolutionary process creates
that's the answer right evolutionary
process creates a being that can make
stuff
and then those beings that make stuff
make stuff and yes we could have one of
those who made us seems really unlikely
but the point is you're already taking
all of the assumptions behind evolution
and automatically accepting them
and then adding another one which is a
creator of this universe which is just
more complex and it buys you nothing new
yeah i mean i like i actually like the
way that went because i don't think that
the
original answer which involved a very
careful framing of occam's razor
gets you to be able to say no here
but an explanation of what
invoking a creator does for the logical
chain of falsification
uh does get you to an answer yep
all right um so that's it well well
maybe there was more of the question but
my sense is you it could be that we have
a creator that's a real live possibility
from the point of view of simulation
which i think is the only way it could
really be but maybe i'm just a limited
person then well now it seems like
you've got so i mean this is this is a
little
don't go on i i just i feel like you're
kind of
i've taken all the sides i'm being
perfectly consistent we could have a
creator i don't see any reason to
imagine that we do
and i don't think the hypothesis
requires falsification in the absence of
evidence that we do we should assume it
false the reason we should assume it
false is it doesn't explain anything
that
it adds assumptions and explains nothing
new right in other words if you're going
to accept that evolution creates very
very powerful creatures then you've
accepted evolution as a creative force
capable of creating what we see here in
the universe that's so darn hard to
explain
and so the point is
the one thing we have found which points
us in the direction of correct
explanations which is that they tend to
assume less or explain more or both
that thing does not suggest that this
hypothesis deserves our attention
yeah
okay i feel like
we'll just leave it there for now
next question
also from discord this week
which was in a tie with the last one
do you know why we have double organs in
our bodies such as two kidneys is there
any explanation for that like
evolutionary malfunction and why not
more than two it looks like we are
limited in two for some reason
yeah that's a good question um
here's one thing i would want to know
you're going to know more about the the
doubling of these organs and we talked a
little bit last week about the doubling
of the thyroid in the cat where ours is
fused but that's right um
but not fused
fused i think it is fused yeah actually
yeah is that right but here's the
question
an ancestor
who lost a kidney kidney died from an
infection or something yeah do they
survive that do they have the pro is it
like an arm where you've got a
programming for if that thing gets
broken
here's how you stay alive to the point
that you can
contribute positively to your fitness
thereafter or
is the ability to remove a kidney a
medical fact that has no
meaning
evolutionarily like the ability to
correct
the uh
post-encephaletic
the encephaletic babies the ability to
correct the
circulatory
the water on the brain problem um and
rescue them from something that would
have killed any ancestor
oh you are you asking me
i don't know if you know
i'm sorry i i was i was thinking
ask it again i didn't take that as i
thought i thought you were going
rhetorical and we're going somewhere and
i have something else to say the kidney
the doubled kidney yeah
uh it means something different
if no ancestor would have ended up
losing a kidney and having a backup and
that was meaningful if you die because
your kidney kills you as it fails except
for the fact of a surgeon taking it out
then
the doubling means something very
different than it's a backup and a
certain number of ancestors lost one
kidney i believe
but um you know i've got a lot of
comparative anatomy background but no
metal explicitly medical background
uh that
kidneys can and do fail sometimes they
can fail spectacularly and take out the
individual even if it's just one kidney
of course that's going to be able to
happen um but that they can fail sort of
silently leaving you with one
functioning kidney so what i would what
i was thinking when i thought you were
speaking rhetorically um
was you know what
i was there there are lots of things
about which we do have many right like
you know why not more than two well we
have more than two white blood cells
right we have lots of things and you
know maybe you will say well that's just
because it moves around you know we
don't we are we are bilaterally
symmetrical
and um therefore we tend to have paired
things to some degree and that allows
for things like uh binocular vision and
um you know stereo sound and even you
know we can triangulate with smells not
us so well because uh we're primates
um
but you know the bilateral the bilateral
symmetry allows for a doubling of sense
organs which allows us to better place
things in in in space
uh the doubling of something like a
kidney
uh potentially i'm thinking about like a
kidney and a liver
so we have one liver but it's got lots
of lobes and it's not discrete in the
same way your liver doesn't fail and
you're done right your liver gets
cirrhosis and you have parts of it that
are not working very well and sometimes
autopsies reveal like wow that's the
thing finally after you know 40 years of
hard drinking or whatever it is
the liver failed
but you don't you don't have the liver
fail early on in in an acute uh an acute
incident often in the same way and what
are the liver in the kidneys they are
detoxifying
um
organs right and of course
also in terms of the kidneys they're
they're concentrating organs
so
you would expect them to have specific
ability to deal with insult and injury
yeah and have the organism go on in the
case of kidney it seems to be about
doubling
i will explain in a second keep going
okay
it's
hard to talk while you're doing that
um
and
the kidneys the kidneys being doubled in
the liver being
having lots of lobes and having not
tending to fail early in the same way
are different responses to a similar
problem that they both deal with
uh what else do we have you know we have
we have one heart but we have two
systems that's different you know the
systemic and the and the pulmonary we
have two lungs
um
i don't i i think the answer to why two
lungs
is
not exactly going to be about it being
paired because at least in mammals which
have the diagnostic characteristic of
the diaphragm which is
the transverse sites actually down here
the transverse septum that separates the
cardiac and pleural cata
cavities from the um all the rest of the
the stuff in the in the ceiling in in
the gut cavity uh beams muscularized in
mammals and becomes the diaphragm and
enables
us as mammals to basically engage in
active and active muscularized breathing
um
so lungs and so so our lungs tend to
tend to work in tandem uh i don't in
that case i think it's just that um
i think it's i think that's going to be
just an artifact in order to call it a
plural cavity
oh god that was a terrible terrible pun
oh no yeah well that's all right
you don't care you know karen it's
actually spelled more similarly than it
might be but it's just an extra e in
there yeah you know so all right
we've got various hypotheses on the
table you can have some doubling as a
matter of redundancy which may well be
the case in the kidney you've got
another mechanism for doing that in the
liver where you have multiple lobes yep
and my guess and they're not exactly
symmetric right yeah
yeah it doesn't matter um
but
i would guess in the case of the lungs
that it is
also a redundancy issue not that an
ancestor would likely lose a lung and
survive to contribute positively to
their fitness but that if you're going
to get a pneumonia it's better to get it
on one side and have it largely isolated
from the other
yes that's true you know so that there's
there's damage that you wouldn't you
would want one lung can keep you alive
and while the other lung is fixing
itself
and of course the reproductive system is
largely duplicated too with the
exception of the actual genitals yep and
and actually
monotremes
have y-shaped penises and vaginas they
do so they have a little doubling there
too which is just odd and then um [ __ ]
mates snakes and penises actually have
have two they have hemi beans
you said snakes and penises
it's not a thing
not even a freudian slip that's just
weird
yeah snakes penises i've shared lizards
yeah squirmates snakes and lizards
they do and you gotta ask yourself well
so i will i do happen to have a story
about this oddly enough about snakes and
penises no lizards in fact okay
years ago when i was working snakes are
right absolutely yeah when i was working
with bob trivers uh it was my first
research gig was in jamaica as you know
and i was trying to come to understand
these lizards and one of the things he
suggested was like you should do a
24-hour focal watch follow one animal
for 24 hours see everything it does
you'd be surprised what you learned and
i must tell you it was a truly
exhausting and frustrating experience at
times but it was super educational as a
biologist just to have a single day of
this one animal yes
so powerful and also
long stretches of boredom oh so much but
then a surprising amount of excitement
actually right so this uh blue animal
one of the many species i know they're
not called animals
norops
um the blue one on jamaica which is one
of
five or six native species yeah
it's a large large animal i was
following a male got a dewlap i think
the ones in jamaica have been renamed
door ops not actually positive because
enolas still exists anyway anyway
whatever it is the large
jamaican blue lizard um this animal had
sex three times
there was a male yeah
and he alternated sides yeah right so it
could be that one side gets exhausted
the other side takes over and so it's
different females three different
females
so i don't know if that's the situation
or if there's a hazard and sometimes an
animal loses one of them and
uses the other anyway but it was
interesting that in that case
alternating sides was a real phenomenon
yeah
yeah yeah um
okay maybe we've maybe we've done enough
on that
let's make some penises question
you're never gonna live it down good
that's fine
that's if that's the error that follows
me that's that's good i'm fine with that
okay um
celibate clergy as a benevolent lineage
counselor
isn't what the status of menopause is
ancestrally supposed to achieve
has the patriarchy taken over that
traditional female role
all right this is from echo somebody's
paying attention not surprising it would
be echo yeah
um here's the thing not exactly but
you're on the right track great question
can i
let's just say it again because i was
sort of stumbling and it might want to
just frame frame the so again the idea
here um is that
i believe echo's probably
following something i said or maybe i
don't know if we put it in the book but
anyway the idea is that a clergy
is in a great position to speak for the
lineage to steer the lineage out of
danger and into opportunity
and that a celibate clergy is especially
good at this because the celibate clergy
especially a celibate clergy that's
taken a vow of poverty or something like
it
does not have a conflict of interest
that is to say um you know the priest is
not hopefully leaving offspring all over
town and
getting rich and
gambling or buying yachts or whatever
he might do
if he is limited to
uh you know an ascetic life and one that
is not directly reproductive and one
that is not
highly profitable and he's in a great
position
not to be corrupted by those things and
to say oh i think we're headed in a bad
direction with that
outbreak of whatever kind of behavior is
happening in the in the
congregation
right so okay speaks for lineage because
his direct opportunity to reproduce or
profit is eliminated
females at hitting menopause
are altered in this direction and in
fact there's lots of stuff dick
alexander my phd advisor used to talk
about the change in women's perspective
at menopause he talked about the change
in their humor also at menopause
interesting stuff changing the way they
laugh he said
but anyway the point is when a woman is
no longer in a position to leave
offspring directly
then it is natural for her sense of what
to do in the world to default to a
larger set but that set is not exactly
lineage in the same sense that a clergy
member who may be you know the authority
for the town is her um
ability to positively affect her fitness
going forward is much more likely to
default to her brood right that is to
say all the offspring she has produced
and all the grand offspring that may
have been produced by them and that is
not distinct from lineage it is a
lineage but it is narrower so what i
would say is
i think you've got exactly the right
theme and as i keep saying to people
the beauty of the idea of lineage is
that it's fractal right so you can say
that a
woman on hitting menopause is going to
default
to a lineage orientation
and that clergy members speak for a
lineage orientation but the meaning of
the term lineage is at a different scale
typically
something like that
cool
have heard
that blondes are about two percent of
the world population and redheads are
going extinct
will we all eventually have black hair
what is different hair color about
anyway
well i would say
there's a couple things i wonder about
the numbers yeah and i wonder why
redheads would be going extinct
um
doesn't
yeah i think a bunch of things need to
need to be on the table cool one um
the meaning of these things is going to
be very different in an ancient world
where these traits initially arose right
where for at least two reasons
okay let me make sure i got them both
uh oh yeah yeah okay
um are we gonna share them yeah okay
let's see if i've got the same two as
you awesome could be three yeah be four
one is that you would tend to have been
inside a population that would probably
have a hair color and that a lot of what
we're seeing now is the intermingling of
populations where you get every
intermediate variant and you get a lot
of shuffling of geographic locations
that's related to one of mine but not
exactly so okay and then the other one
is going to be
um
people who are trans hair color
go to the market and
get something and alter their hair color
because they were you know
they were born into the
head of wrong hair yeah they were born
into the wrong hair
oh this is good yeah yeah yeah so we
basically had the same two um i guess i
was framing the first one uh more as
um and this is sort of related to what
is different hair color about anyway um
that
many people in the world not all by any
means and in fact the not all are much
more likely to be within equatorial
ranges regions who are much more likely
to have black hair or darker hair at
least
people
do not live where their ancestors lived
anymore and travel lots of places and so
um you know blondness shows up many
places where blindness never would have
shown up before yeah so um you know
blondness
evolves closer to the poles and
precisely closer to the north pole
because that's where most the landmass
you know there's much more land on earth
and therefore people on earth close to
the north pole than close to the south
pole
and blonde people have certainly um you
know populated out various places but
um
but i'm not sure exactly where i was
going with that well let's just say uh
blondness tends to evolve near the poles
but the poles tend to be brown haired
they're brunettes i see are they i think
so
i don't know if they are actually um i
don't i don't have an image of sort of
the stereotypical polish person in my
head and then gosh i don't know
redheadedness
irish
right but where else i don't know i
don't i don't know what the redhead
thing is about with regard you know if
we're not talking about comes from a
bottle right which is the silly
shorthand but you know if it's what
you're born with
um
so bl blondness in part
um presumably in part
is basically allowing you to do some
some vitamin d synthesis through your
scalp
um right that uh that if you are you
know just as people have darker skin
near the equator
which
which
if if their ancestors evolved were more
recently nearer to the equator they're
more likely to have darker skin and
darker hair
which is protection against
the harmful rays of the sun but it also
the flip side of that is that they would
have to spend a lot more time in the sun
in order to generate sufficient amounts
of vitamin d which is part of why people
who are more recently from equatorial
regions who move to temperate and even
arctic regions are much more likely to
be vitamin d deficient than people
moving the other direction you know
swedish people moving to the tropics are
going to need to worry about sunburn
quite a lot
but are unlikely to worry to need to
worry about vitamin d synthesis if they
spend any time outside at all because
between the sun being able to reach you
know through their hair into their scalp
and also all of that pale skin
vitamin d synthesis is relatively
relatively easy with all the other
caveats about age makes you less
efficient at vitamin d synthesis um
being overweight does a variety of um
autoimmune disorders and and some other
medical conditions do as well living in
your mother's basement will do it living
in your mother's basement makes it very
hard to synthesize vitamin d yes
especially if she has glass in the
windows in her basement that just barely
peek over the uh
the pavement outside which guys you
should really talk to her about that
yeah you might want to mention that just
like talk to her or anyone really right
yeah um talk to her outside just yeah
exactly just have a conversation maybe
some coffee
it's gotten ridiculous very quickly but
i do want to point out a couple things
um one
hair itself is a bit of a weird
phenomenon in persons
um
yeah didn't come out as good as i was
hoping being people let's just say um
because the thing is that the
distinction between hair and fur right
the cat
um yeah
yeah i will show you see this is the cat
and the cat has what is commonly
referred to
as
fur which basically is a hair of fixed
length it grows and then it stops
growing
and hair doesn't stop growing which
raises all kinds of questions about the
ancestors but
the point is why did we lose so much of
what was presumably fur at one point
and why did we end up with hair instead
and why on the top of our heads and why
and why is none of our hair a goodie
right exactly i mean this the tabby
thing
is uh this is completely irrelevant to
the question but the tabby thing
is i don't won't be able to show this
but if you have a tabby at home you
should try this at home
just look at his haunches or her
haunches as the case may be
and see how individual furs actually
have three or in some cases four
distinct colors
when an individual fur has basically
striations you end up with this tabby
this sort of modeled look and
while individual hairs can occasionally
on on humans can occasionally be
can switch color midway that's that's
rare and it seems to be about like a
stress event often right and
that hair went gray yeah
um
so the obviously the uh in the case of
fur which has this goody banding issue
it's obviously a matter of timing that
the follicle basically puts out a
different color at different points and
it knows how far it is along
the individual hair but anyway point is
hair is itself a bit of a weird thing
and that we have it on the top of our
heads
i don't know that i've heard a great
explanation of
why a creature that lost
fur ended up with hair on the top of its
heads maybe somebody's figured it out
yeah there's one anthropological
hypothesis which i'm not sure i buy
which involves um
you know going um bipedal at the moment
that you're um also you know basically
going bipedal means that now you don't
need as much of the fur to protect
yourself from the potentially burning
rays of the sun but why not keep it on
the part of your head that is most
exposed to the sun that assumes it's
always right overhead yeah i'm not sure
i buy this
i don't know i mean i've had that
thought but it just somehow it just
doesn't sense it doesn't have the sense
of like oh yeah that explains it i agree
um but anyway okay so other interesting
facts that are relevant here um a place
that we have gone somewhat frequently
san juan island
has foxes i'm going to tell you the
story of the foxes because it's weird
and fascinating
the foxes were introduced to san juan
island which does not natively have
foxes the foxes that were introduced are
red foxes the foxes were introduced to
control the rabbits the rabbits were
introduced to feed the lighthouse keeper
which i think is actually
it's sort of um
it is backwards ecologically right as
ecologically sensitive people the idea
of introducing a species to feed the
lighthouse keeper isn't how you would
want it done on the other hand how great
a plan is that that you take a rapidly
reproducing herbivore you introduce it
it spreads like wildfire spreads like
rabbits it does spread like rabbits and
then you hunt them as needed
um
for sustenance and then they get out of
control and then you introduce the foxes
but why do i tell you this hey zach
actually heather you could do it you
want to uh
get a picture of one of the melanistic
foxes from san juan island they're not
too hard to come by you just keep on so
the thing is on san juan island these
foxes have been there
uh it's not 200 years it's
more like a hundred years um you want um
any one of those
that's one with both oh okay that'll
work
um okay
so okay so here we have a picture of a
red fox and a black silver tipped fox
and the point that i wanted the black
ones being called melanistic the same
same root as melanin yep yep
point i wanted to make is that the
evolutionary change in coloration
because we know when this population
started i don't happen to know offhand
but it wasn't a very long time is some
radically
powerful kind of selection did this and
or
the
system inside the fox is built to detect
some kind of selective pressure and
respond to it very rapidly nonetheless
and yet both both forms both morphs do
persist on senwa island absolutely they
do and i would guess
that oh um i would guess
that that's uh
eating a rabbit
um i think that might be their mother or
their animal but yeah um anyway the
point is
that
especially with respect to sexual
selection
it would not be surprising if markers
that indicated something in some
reliable way
emerged
and
you know how would you get selection to
change the color of a fox population
well it might be that females facing an
interesting puzzle like this is not a
very big gene pool and therefore we've
got problems with
um deleterious recessive genes in a way
that the mainland population doesn't
they might select for individuals
select for males that have an indicator
that they're from a population that
didn't have such a big problem with that
which could come in the form of color
which would then predict
over time that the strange melonism
would disappear right that it's a
solution to a temporary problem
i also believe that the same phenomenon
not on san juan island but in other
places has rapidly produced black
squirrels so my guess would be that
there's some sort of a mechanism
whereby
uh
it's an honest indicator of
a
probably a genetic state that is
relevant to sexual selection and that's
why you end up seeing it
so my point is in the context of humans
you can have functional differences
but you might also have signaling
differences
and it would have to be an honest
indicator i think it would have to be an
honest indicator in order for selection
to favor its elaboration
in other words females who chose on the
basis of such a characteristic and came
out ahead would therefore cause that
characteristic to be elaborated yeah
i guess
this is this is not directly relevant to
what you're saying but i'm just thinking
like the the origins of blondes and
redheads i think in both cases it's like
it's north atlantic and scandinavia
because their
vikings
have been redheaded as well
and so it's
like actually both of those are coming
from the same place
i don't think i don't think you have
a aside from sort of albinism
which is a complete lack of pigment i
don't think you have blondes or redheads
um natively in the americas
in africa
in asia
in australia
and not even in southern europe i think
it's entirely i think it's coming out of
northern europe and north atlantic
well
i may be wrong no i think that's right i
like it and i guess one thing i'm
thinking is there might be a distinction
between a population sandwiched between
two other populations and a population
with
humans on one edge and not the other
that an edge population might have
different uh selective forces on it
edger island yeah yeah all edge yep
cool
each generation since world war ii has
gotten increasingly childish and
arrested in development
puberty blockers seem to be a case of us
manifesting that into existence now as
the next phase
as the next phase
can this make sense evolutionarily
i know you are but what am i
i was just being childish i don't know
um
i i got the gist of the question we're
seeing an infantilization of a an
accelerating infantilization and then
what was the
uh can this make sense evolutionarily
it's like puberty blocker seems to be a
case of us manifesting that into
existence now as the next phase
i guess i don't feel like that's
i feel like that's not quite the way it
works but i'm not sure that there's a
way it works that's been proposed
exactly so i think
i think the answer to the question is um
neonate can make sense in some cases but
progressive
like a regression
doesn't likely make sense so neotony is
a very precise version of the larger
thing which is pitomorphosis which is uh
retains juvenile characteristics as an
adult reproductive form
is what i mean yeah um i'm just defining
terms here um
you know it's been it's been proposed
uh
and taken seriously in some quarters
that that's what the humans are humans
are the pedomorphic ape that we have we
retain juvenile characteristics that our
heads are bigger than you would expect
our eyes are better than you would
expect
um maybe we say things like i know you
are but what am i more than you would
expect uh for another linguistic ape um
i have said it more than you would
expect in my adult life which is to say
once once yes um
and i'm not i'm not i've never been
really compelled by this hypothesis but
um but what you were saying was uh that
metamorphosis as this
known
evolutionary thing in which for instance
let me just take it out of humans for
the moment um some salamanders so
salamanders amphibians amphibians
amphibious can live well in both water
and land but generally at different life
stages typically we find aquatic eggs
and larval forms that metamorphose into
terrestrial forms there are some
circumstances in which
you would either want the possibility
and so be facultatively metamorphic like
do i metamorphose or do i retain my
larval form even as my gonads develop or
circumstances in which actually all of
us are gonna stick in the water so we're
gonna become obligate pedomorphs we're
never gonna metamorphose there's
salamanders therefore that
do not
um lose their tail fins and the webbing
between their toes and their gills for
instance and a bunch of other internal
stuff that allows them you know they
don't they don't develop
lungs for instance um the way they would
if they were metamorphic
humans obviously don't go through this
kind of metamorphosis at all but is you
know are we pedomorphic yeah
not really yeah i would point out though
there is an interesting case here in the
pacific northwest of a salamander
that
uh
is pedomorphic
behaviorally and facultatively without
being morphologically pedomorphic which
begins to say something about this human
case what you're talking about um i'm
talking about the rough skin newt
that the
males in many populations do not leave
the water yeah um
so they do so they don't um
it's interesting they've got some
pedomorphic traits and some not they do
not
i don't think retain the external gills
they don't they have lungs
but um external morphologically they do
retain a tail fin and some some webbing
um so they're good at swimming they're
good at moving through water yep better
at moving through water
than they would be if they had fully
transformed in a terrestrial form but
the really important stuff around
respiration did not
did go pedomorphic in them yeah yeah um
so
anyway behavioral paedomorphosis is a
real thing but i think
the person asking the question
the answer is my instinct and i think
your instinct is
um no this is not an adaptation humans
getting less and less mature it is the
result of hyper novelty disrupting a
developmental process and it ain't good
for us and let's cut it out before we do
something stupid and go extinct indeed
so that's maybe kind of sort of related
to this next question which claims
humans will eventually have the
technology to change sex as easily
safely cheaply and reversibly as we
change clothes
that day is not today and could be 200
years from now but how do we ethically
bridge that gap given that it
necessarily involves experimentation on
kids and many failed cases will fall
into the uncanny valley
ain't never going to happen it's my
feeling yeah i think
i
knew that
i knew that i did and was almost certain
that you would reject the assumption of
the question which is in the first
sentence the first sentence being again
humans will eventually have the
technology to change sex as easily
safely cheaply and reversibly as we
change clothes
um it's i mean it's
frankly it's easy to say no way um
when you add reversibly um as we change
clothes there uh you know
is it
barely within the realm of possibility
that we could have the capacity to
change all of the systems
um
once and only once thus making a human
an actual a single individual human an
actual one-time functional hermaphrodite
i don't think so but that's at least
something that we could talk about with
regard to the complexity of the systems
and all of this but the idea of kind of
going back and forth and actually being
functional as the other sex
it's just it's it's just too much
there's just no way yeah i i don't think
i think it is barely plausible
that in a small number of cells you
could make an alteration that would
cause an individual to go down the
alternative pathway it would be
irreversible and it would be pointless
to do it in a small number of cells you
might as well do it at the gamete i mean
at the zygote
so you have a single cell and this i
mean this is the point actually right
like um we talk about sexual development
right it's not a toggle it's not like
there are two states and so the states
are binary and we think of zeros and
ones and like oh just make the zero one
just make the one is here like no it
takes years it takes years and no we're
not a metamorphic species but we do go
through puberty which is a kind of like
metamorphosis light and so you can't
just say um you know turn those i don't
even know what the analogies are i know
we know them they're the homologs but
like
turn the female
reproductive structures into male ones
like it it it can't work that way and so
you know
the only thing that i see here as a
remote possibility and why would you
ever
is
could we develop the technology to turn
for instance an xx embryo
into a functional
male adult you know into someone that
developed through puberty as male into a
functional male adult
maybe
but that would
like why right like why would you do
that
yes why would you do that and
um
anything that starts later or imagines
that you could do it multiple times
uh or you know or or forgets that it's
not just
it's not just reproductive it's not just
the primary sex characteristics right
it's it there is masculinization or
feminization of the brain
of
um the endocrine system and there are
with regard to endocrinology
there are effects of hormones especially
the steroid hormones especially the sex
hormones like the androgens testosterone
and stoned ion like the estrogens
and progesterone
which have not just activation effects
which is to say ah turn it on now get um
you know a rush of energy i don't know
but also organizational effects which is
to say
when
you have
those hormones in development they
organize your system so that those
systems then follow different pathways
you become cannalized
and those developmental systems can't
just suddenly become other things they
would have to go through a whole other
developmental process in order to be so
so it strikes me in thinking about this
in this context
that
this has a lot to do with actually the
last question about immaturity and the
point is
everything that we perceive
is inherently the reason that we bother
perceiving it the reason that we bother
thinking about it is about the future
you may be dwelling on the past but
you're dwelling on the past because the
past has some implication that is worth
spending your effort on the past cannot
be changed and this is like an obsession
with changing the past right
the idea of i was born in the wrong body
is instead of saying well okay here are
the cards i was dealt you know um maybe
you're a
uh
a woman with
a very masculine orientation to the
world
okay what are you gonna make of that the
answer is you can make a lot of that
right
you are such a woman right
or
you could lament the fact that something
and something else don't fit together in
the way that somebody told you they were
supposed to and then you know you can
rail against the
you know the
cursed biology and
try to go back and un-biology it and
you know it's like okay a
it's not liable to work all that well
um and b it mis you know it's a
misorientation the point is look if you
walk out into the street and you get hit
by a bus and you lose your arm yep
you're gonna end up grieving your arm
but at some point and it's gonna be the
best moment of your life going forward
you're going to move on right right
you're going to say well i am a person
with one arm and
um
let's live my best life with one arm
because it's about the future
irrespective of whether you got you know
you may have gotten hit by a drunk
driver and you lost your arm are you is
it okay to be mad yes but the point is
if what you are is mad from then on then
you won't do any of the things that you
might do even with just the one arm
right
great
um
i think there's a typo in this question
um
what it says is our individual is able
to evolve resistance to iokine powder
which if i change that i took to a c
it's cocaine
no is i okay in a thing it is a thing
but okay what kind of a thing it is zach
do you know what i okane is
okay um well okay zach's gonna look it
up and we'll move on and then um we'll
come back
okay what is it okay well you you
figured out and get back to us and we
are going to move on to the next
question okay
oh okay um
i don't
well then
um glendon
whose
last name which is presumably a num de
plume you've seen in them i've never
known how to pronounce um
we can't answer it because it's
unfortunately it's been a couple years
since we've seen princess bride
um i don't remember i okay powder yeah i
sort of do what does it do
it's just poison
is it the one where they have the
battle over whether which cup it's in
it's that one yes oh actually i can hear
the guy's voice now yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay
yep
that's the one
um what was the question in line are
individuals able to evolve resistance to
and powder yes
okay what does it mean
yes he's poisoned both cut the answer is
it's not in one country
yeah it's certain i mean it's it's the
thinking behind homeopathy it's the
thinking a little bit behind um vaccines
actually um you know exposure to a thing
you know and obviously vaccines are
different than toxins they're not the
same thing um the immune system um is is
is evolving in a way
in a way that typically uh your ability
to respond to particular toxins does not
but you know can you build a resistance
yeah i mean there are actually
um this is this is also i think i think
if memory serves part of what
snake charmers do like they work really
hard not to get uh bitten uh but they
what
well i have this little hypothesis about
what snake charmers do well
okay but eliminating the
venom glands and or
fangs well they some of them
claim anyway and i just i have not gone
back to to assess the veracity of the
claims or what i think the rest of the
claims is um that they are exposing
themselves to small amounts uh
much like with the proposed the supposed
iocane powder
i think it's bull but i'd be
fascinated to find out otherwise
i will say
i i think where we land here tell me if
i've got it wrong
is many things you can build up a
tolerance to there are liable to be
things that are exceptions in fact there
almost certainly are so icane powder you
probably could develop an immunity but a
land war in asia probably not um
yeah yeah yeah okay
yeah yeah so don't
don't go get uncomfortable with that
yeah yeah exactly
uh happy easter and passover to you both
much love thank you yes thank you
here we are
i have never understood the rituals of
easter i just feel like i need to say
that
i'm not against people having a good one
i just the rituals of easter i find
kind of alice in wonderland like that's
very alice in wonderland like oh for
sure
the little bunny on san juan island ate
some from the cup that said he became a
big pastel colored floppy-eared
egg-bearing
[Laughter]
okay um
do you think many people will
realistically catch
i don't even know how to pronounce them
because i've only read that is it ba.1
is that how we pronounce it or is it ba1
the omicron variants do you know how do
we say it ba1 i don't know yeah so yeah
okay do you think many people will
realistically catch ba1 and then also
ba2 or xe i feel like authorities want
us to think so
thank you
um
i'm very concerned
that this thing came out of a lab and
therefore is not going to abide by any
of the normal rules and intuitions
so you're talking about
two plus years ago not not also maybe
omicron being having come out of a
separate lab
omicron maybe possibly having come out
of separate lab is not required for your
concern to be salient not at all and in
fact there's a way in which the
weirdness of omicron
could be also a consequence of the
initial laboratory uh environment you
know in other words right
you
do serial passage in humanized mice it
escapes into a
human uh associated mice
that's a large population it makes
changes it returns to humans because
you've increased its tropism that kind
of thing
but basically my feeling is
i think i hear almost everybody
trying to infer what's going to happen
based on the way these things tend to
behave and the problem is
the future won't look like the past if
this is the first time ever that you've
had a chimeric virus emerge
globally it may tend
it may tend to revert to a normal state
right but
i believe we have done the worst thing
that we could do which is bridge a gap
it would not have jumped on its own and
having done so it is now
like an invasive in hawaii
yeah and so anyway i'm concerned that
the rules about natural immunity as much
as we saw them reflected in early phases
of this may break down
and i don't like it
yeah you want to
you want to say anything more about
about that
um
let's put it this way we have lots of
uh
pathogens that circulate by virtue of
some interaction between
uh
the way they produce natural immunity
that isn't maybe so effective and the
way they change and the inner you know
you keep getting colds for example and
some of that is you getting a descendant
of the pathogen you've already had which
would be better if you didn't
um
so the question is did we fast-forward
the process
what did we do here and
um
again i would um and given the people
we've also talked about
not only is the tropism very very high
but the range of tissues that are
impacted by this thing is also
anomalously high for reasons that i
believe also have to do with the
laboratory origin and so
um
you know
what the hell anthony found you yeah
it's not
it's really not like
anything else
that we've seen
that we individually have experienced
and certainly and you know it's not
we can talk in terms of you know what's
the ifr you know the uh infection
fatality rate or the you know the cfr
compared to other coronaviruses or flu
for instance and of course the
comparison to flu early on was uh much
lambasted and um
and it wasn't really appropriate then
because people were doing exactly the
thing they were conflating like does it
have a similar
um
effectively death rate that's a
simplification
to flu or does it not and given that we
live with flu what the hell why are we
shutting down things over this that's a
that's a question
that then tends to let people lead
people to think like well it's the flu
yes i know people die of the flu but
mostly they're very old is that true of
covid yes
but
if this is as frankly all the evidence
suggests it is a lab creation and given
that it causes
sets of symptoms that are not like
anything else the you know the anosmia
the the loss of smell and taste that
many people experience the lesions that
some people get the um like the blisters
on the i've never seen or heard directly
of anyone but
people get on like the pads of their
fingers and toes
um
the brain fog these aren't things that
you get with a cold whether the
coronaviruses they just they're not
things that you get with the flu right
these aren't you know these like
one-off very weird symptoms are the
kinds of things you expect from the
kinds of exotic tropical vector diseases
like mosquito vector diseases that we
have tried to protect ourselves against
in other places so
um it's a it's a weird exotic thing
that
if you're just counting deaths
um
doesn't seem to have a very high death
rate especially if you treat for it um
but
uh what are the long-term effects of
having
been exposed to it multiple times if you
end up with symptoms like what does it
persist in tissues does it take does it
affect longevity this is a question that
we don't hear
people talking about yeah or at least
not very well and i would i
if you take the model some model uh
i advanced back in the telomere days
which is that every disease
robs you of longevity right right
um you know even a common cold the point
is they don't typically rob you of very
much
yeah
and if let's say that we talk about
every respiratory virus that you've had
in your life
everyone robs you of a little bit
because they take the tissues that you
depend on for respiration and they
uh cause cells to die and have to be
replaced but well but so the argument
there though would would be contingent
on
they will they will have robbed you of
some life
if
it's those respiratory tissues
that reach the end of their you know hit
their hayflick limit
at first among all of your cells if
that's the thing that takes you out
exactly what i'm getting at is
if you take every respiratory disease
that you've had and you imagine they all
rob you of some longevity but most
people don't die from the failure of
their lungs then the point is you don't
tend to see that effect very strongly
right it's there
but in the case of something like sars
kovi 2
which
impacts many many tissues and the
argument that i've put forward before is
that that's because if you give this
disease to a bunch of ferrets in a cage
in a laboratory they don't have to keep
functioning well as ferrets in order to
spread it unlike a wild disease
that has to keep its host healthy enough
to to succeed so the anosmia in
particular
um is conspicuous because a ferret that
can't smell probably starves to death so
the point is but a ferret in a cage
doesn't need to smell in order to find
its chow
so we may have created
symptoms that wouldn't accompany an
ordinary disease but the point is if the
thing is damaging lots of tissues around
the body
right
then the point is it's not like a
respiratory virus where you have to
ultimately die of the failure of your
lungs in order to see the effect it's
had on your longevity the point is if
it's expiring
you know a little bit of liver a little
bit i don't know what tissues it's
affecting but many many tissues by
virtue of the way it interfaces with
circulation and the point is well you're
going to die of the failure of one of
those things aren't you right and if you
do you know you don't have to cancer is
sort of the opposite of the failure of
these systems but you're very likely to
die from the failure of some system
right
it's going to be something like half of
deaths that are not the result of trauma
right um
so
if that's the case then the chances that
it will burn some of the
longevity you had in that tissue are
high which means the effect on longevity
is going to be much
more widespread right
and that's associated with the
prediction that there will be an
increase in cancers across many systems
so it also seems to be somehow
liberating cancers that people had that
were functioning very slowly or things
that were prototumors and things like
that so you basically have cancer and
failure of an organ as opposite failure
modes right
and both of these things seem to be
impacted
um by this disease so anyway it's a very
it's a very frightening disease i did
want to correct one thing though you
said yes loss of taste and smell
now absolutely people lose their sense
of smell but i think a lot of the people
who say they've lost their sense of
taste never had taste in the first place
oh okay i stand corrected
i was talking to a wonderful woman this
week who who um i assure you did and she
now has it again
um but did in fact lose both and she had
taste in both senses of the word really
yes oh yes that's like it's like a
redundant backup sense of taste yeah
um
no
no not at all different different
totally different same spellings it
spelled it
yep
um okay i don't know
we got a couple questions here uh we're
closing out an hour aren't we
okay um i don't know geert vandenbush's
recent warning is dire
uh mass facts
races are on how to amplify this warning
i don't know his i don't know what he
said recently i haven't seen it yeah um
i think figuring out how
accurate garrett has been and where he
has been inaccurate is important because
a lot of what he says is highly
consequential and i think he was very
right about the question of variance i
don't know if he was fully right about
the consequence of the proliferation of
variance it may have been less severe in
terms of its impact
which is not to say it wasn't severe but
anyway
look i think he's done really important
work i'm proud to have uh put him on
dark horse and talked about this stuff
because i think he
his model has been largely borne out but
in terms of a dire warning i want to see
the content and figure out you know if
we if we
say well how accurate was he you've got
a question of
um
kind and a question of intensity and i
think he's done better on kind than
intensity as far as i know so far
um so anyway i would
yeah um i guess i'm not as familiar and
it's been a while since i thought about
that and i was not as familiar with
exactly uh his his thinking and his
hypotheses but it seems to me that the
intensity part
was um
and he stated that it was more that was
more guesswork that you know he he said
this will happen if you mass vaccinate
in the middle of a pandemic you will
create variance that's that seems to
have happened
um and then he said
and you know maybe in part because he's
like yelling into the void and trying to
get attention on something that he's
really worried about um said you know
this is serious because here's why and
then that part which is the intensity
part of your argument
wasn't
predicted inherently that was a you know
that was that was guesswork that was
less
that was
he i think knew that he was standing on
less solid scientific ground with regard
to the intensity part of the argument
anyway that that was sort of a follow-on
too like and when that happens here's
why we should care well actually this is
this is i think
philosophically important yeah because
one who predicts for a living yeah
always has this problem right predicting
what will happen is tough but it's far
easier than predicting exactly how it
plays out when exactly it plays out so
for example
you know
when evergreen came apart
i very clearly said look this is going
to spill into the world it's going to
get into the courts it's going to get
into
you know every medium right
i was still shocked by how fast it went
down and how quickly we got to the blm
riots and the sort of mass insanity yeah
so the point is even somebody who sees
it as clearly as anybody does doesn't
necessarily
have the same level of resolution on
when and how it's going to unfold
exactly so i i do not mean in any way to
detract from what garrett has done is
just like you've got
you know what's going to happen is hard
enough how exactly it's going to happen
is virtually impossible yep totally
okay um
one last question this is nice heather
you're looking great any tips love you
guys
um
i i just i thank you for that um
i've been moving a lot more
and uh winter winter's tough winter's
always tough
and i am definitely feeling not having
been in the tropics for over two years
at this point which
uh which just makes it which i love and
makes everything feel easy and fluid and
um it's easy to move but
um even with
boy the you know so last week we said
wow we had a day
now nine days ago it was 75 degrees here
early early april i actually went out
paddle boarding for the first time this
season it was amazing
three days later four days later uh it
was
snowing enough for our wonderful house
guests and their three and a half year
old daughter who had never before seen
snow to build a snowman
in our front on our front patio uh the
remnants of which still persist even
though since then it is hailed here
800 times like it is hailed here so many
times so intensely and then we have this
thunderstorm just now
like this incredible stochasticity is
is worrisome for sure um anyway that
that all makes it a little bit more
difficult to want to move around but i
think um
anyone who just does get into the habit
and presumably almost all of us have
been in the habit
and if it's for me if it's a sport back
when i played volleyball or ultimate um
it was easier it's like oh there's other
people going to be there we can have fun
it's great um and when it's biking which
both you and i have done a lot of and
you've been doing more of it lately than
i have
uh it's a little harder to motivate
because you're only letting yourself
down and it's not social
yeah i will also say on that front it is
easier and better to keep doing it as
the weather gets rotten than to try to
pick it up
almost every year that we have lived in
this climate or worse
um there's some point in the winter
where you get sick and there are weeks
that you don't get on your bike and then
it's much harder to go back to it's
almost hard to remember how you do it
and stay warm yeah um you know you
either overdress and you go out and
you're sweating and then you're clammy
and then exactly
um so anyway there's so i think there's
something and you're making this point
to to uh trying to be consistent rather
than
um you know
try to
bootstrap your way back to it in the
middle of the winter yeah and i guess
the thing that has helped me just just
recently
um
is
trying to be conscious to raise to
consciousness
during a day that i have been moving and
that i've been um i've also been i
really like sugar i really like baking
things and i like eating baked goods but
i've been doing less of that and
i love the process of making
goodies for people i love and for me and
eating them but almost nothing else in
the day is better like nothing else in
the day is better as a result yeah and
so bringing to consciousness in any day
that i have been active and that i have
only eaten um delicious nutritious food
that is that is good for me um all the
other moments actually feel better it's
easier to run up the stairs it's easier
to you know not fall on a slippery deck
and being being grateful like ah
that's in part because i'm i'm doing
these things and i'm i'm more i'm more
capable now
helps reinforce like actually
i'm not gonna have that delicious
cranberry almond muffin
after all well okay so this this raises
a point i think one of the reasons that
um we all have these challenges is
that when you're young
the impact of making bad decisions of
this kind tends not to be significant
and maybe not noticeable so what it is
is that the existence of hazards that
actually do have an impact but it
doesn't rise above some threshold of
compromising
um
trains you badly that these things you
know yeah there are lots of people out
there who talk about avoid this avoid
that but i i don't detect anything and
then at the point that you're old enough
that you do start detecting that stuff
you actually have to a work to see the
pattern and that b you've got bad habits
that you got to unlearn i had this
problem in particular and i can actually
think of three ways that my body just is
different now that responds differently
to things so as you know
in high school uh the first retail job
that i had was working at baskin-robbins
and we were allowed it was totally legit
the owner of this particular shop like
we allowed to take a pint home every
night and i would take a pint home and i
would eat it
and i was also playing varsity
volleyball and i was
very thin and very strong and you know i
was i was i had no extra weight as a
result of eating that much ice cream on
the regular basis you know three four
five times a week i was eating a pint of
ice cream at night and it was fine
and
there's been part of me until fairly
recent i was like why can't i just keep
doing that and i don't do that but um
similarly uh
i just had an incredibly high tolerance
for alcohol and i never burned
right right never and so you watch like
okay starting around maybe when i turned
40 got my first sunburn ever like okay
that's going to be different then
started becoming a little bit more
sensitive to alcohol okay you can't um
can't just go out on occasion and have a
bunch of bunch of drinks and expect not
to have it come back to you so you know
we change our bodies change this is part
of what we argue in the book like
even if
there was a best diet for all humans who
were 20 years old which there's not
because the inuit and the maasai both
exist
there can't be a best diet um that is
for a you know a two-year-old baby and a
fourteen-year-old
uh young man and a 25 year old pregnant
woman
and a 50 year old guy and an 80 year old
woman
those people all have different
nutritional needs and their bodies work
differently and they will do better with
different diets and they need to listen
to their own feedback systems in order
to figure out what to eat yeah um i
totally agree with this you do look
great and
you're the pointer that you're making is
a an important one that it's it's almost
like an untaught life skill just paying
attention so that you can detect cause
and effect
yeah um is a key a key thing that that
everybody should learn and we do a very
poor job in civilization of conveying
that well in part again you know
again because of this right because of
what we talk about in hunter-gatherer's
guide to the 21st century hyper novelty
makes it much harder to do pattern
recognition yeah right
there's so much more noise
that it's it's harder it feels like i'm
just going to give up i'm just going to
guess and then and many of the systems
the biofeedback systems in our body
actually take so much time
that ad you know any given day has so
much noise in it as noise compared to
pattern but add to that the fact that
you might not detect even a signal in
six weeks well how are you going to tell
right you have to be you have to
you have to be very careful with
yourself in order to tell for some
things you have to become very good at
um
you know there's lots of noise you have
to be very good at not talking yourself
into something that isn't a correlation
but that you saw a connection once
effectively a superstitious
level of thinking
and you have to be systematic about
reducing the number of impacts of things
that are impacting you in order to be
able to detect the consequence of those
things that you are intersecting with
which
it's worth doing but it it's not uh
it's not easy yeah exactly
all right well i think that that brings
us to the end here
uh we will be doing that private q a on
our patreons next sunday which is going
to be april 24th
at 11 a.m
pacific for members of my patreon our
next public live stream is not going to
be until thursday april 28th and then
we've got a weird schedule
thereafter for a little bit uh but
consider joining us at our private q a
it's a lot of fun we actually pay
attention to the chat and get to
interact a little bit oh and i thought
the thing i forgot to mention is that
the question asking period is right now
so if you join right now you can ask
questions that we then um may get to in
the q a
um
i think otherwise
we're there i think we're there until we
see you next be good to the ones you
love eat good food and get outside be
well everyone
all right
[Music]
[Music]
you